all right welcome back to sticks of
football and another special interview
as we are less than two weeks away from
the NFL Draft and we got an awesome
guest with us here today Darnay holmes
former cornerback at UCLA former
returner
the man does it all and he is here with
us today Darnay I gotta ask you off the
top man with the quarantine with
coronavirus going on what have you been
up to it have you been able to train
what's it like for you right now
yeah first foremost thank you guys for
having is a pleasure always Lincoln I
don't be sure important been there since
day one you guys did my my little
Hollywood BDS so many video exactly but
outside of that this was the quarantine
you know I'm just relaxing no but also
make sure and checking off my objectives
you know working out getting my cardio
here cuz you know a lot of people need
to understand that this is just testing
your dry you know testing if you really
pay for this you know so the other day
these things are inevitable and it came
at a not the greatest time but it came
out of time we're probably the world
needs it so my main thing just made Sean
stay in the shade you know I make sure
that right when I hit that field again
I'm able to contribute you know make a
lasting impression yeah that's awesome
and I know that you're somebody that is
obviously pretty driven and
self-motivated because you graduated in
less than three years and because of
that as an underclassmen you know got to
go to the Senior Bowl left school ready
for the NFL how hard was that to
graduate in that short amount of time
yeah you know for me eyes came out with
the phrase if you have a strict routine
it's hard for you to be swayed away by
abstractions you know so I had a strict
routine you know and when the division
has been you know you're gonna do in
line with this so it was our you know
I'm not gonna sugarcoat it
sugar-coated you know went through every
emotion you know went through times
where I'm lying and I'm not about to
graduate in three years I want to push
back this class you know take a pass or
no pass you know because it's times
where I could have handled the material
those times where my mind was in the
right place because they don't come on
outside but I knew that pretty much
things I know things I was going to a
life
we'll never match up the things I'll go
to my academic field other than my
football field so if I can during these
life lessons did I can do anything that
comes within the realm I place myself
into yeah that's a lot of hard work and
so I got to ask you what are you doing
off the field to break it up I mean I
know understand you're training non-stop
you've been super busy even since the
season ended it's been go-go-go for you
but is there any way any off the field
activities that are also you know
freeing up your time a little bit
keeping you keeping that mental state
and clean yes before you guys gotta fund
all you do a daily devotional I read my
book in the morning I read a chapter
from the Bible and today versus pretty
much saying that always understand
what's coming from the time because
that's coming from your heart you know
so so be watchful of your thoughts but
also be watch it was coming from your
heart because our desires will be you
know amplify once I reached in rebel you
know once you get this money you know
who you are with be show thank you
though yes no making sure that I'm
showing my true colors you know I'm
expressing myself and what I would
express myself in contributes today's I
want to contribute but outside of that
you know nighttime being my girl played
trouble last night and play connect four
you know we just create our own vibe but
we say we had to close so recharge music
off-key rocks yeah she had all my school
so yesterday she was trained out she's I
hear we had too much fun at the club so
things like that I keep those dollars it
keeps us in a right perspective that's
great and like I said before it's been a
long process for you because after the
season ended you went into the Senior
Bowl obviously you're one of the guys
that actually ran at the combine not a
lot of guys want to work out of the
combat anymore and I think that's
something that is a strength for you how
many teams have you been talking to
whether it's senior bowl combine or
these FaceTime interviews like we're
doing right now
yeah for sure I can give a accurate
amount of state I personally you know
it's been a blessing you know just
saying all these organizations willing
to just be total God compassionately
California Nova also knew that
I deserve the recognition I'm getting
you know I never was a person who's out
there just to be recognized amount to
just to be felt you know some people
could see my work ethic people to see my
child people see the value I can add to
them so it's just a blessing they have
these coaches called me up no speaking
to GM head coaches speaking of people
that you never touch you to speak to you
know so just a blessing is to be around
these guys grab inside for them and see
what they want their organization to be
within the next four to five years and I
think the film speaks for itself and so
does the combine numbers but how is the
Senior Bowl week experience for you
because I was down there and I always
watch the corners and receivers I think
it's the best part of Senior Bowl week
and it felt like you had a really really
strong week down there even in
one-on-ones where let's be real that's
not a fair set up for corner backs in
practice yeah so it took a lot of
literally film study like people to
understand that if I was a singer beau I
hit up my the person who's in charge of
the excellence and I told him I need all
these receivers game film you know so I
did my homework before I got out there
so once I got out there you know I was
at a state of on that piece because I I
know what you're gonna do you know I
know the type of relationship you know
so I have I want to say to hope for him
but within myself I know that I'll
declare myself you know but outside of
that it was times where we had a meeting
after the senior beau and I stayed in to
the I stayed in the meeting room for
extra hours like a washing 101 figure
out what I did wrong and I took notice
of I don't have a consistent precedence
my stance was up and down my stairs was
lingering you know I was off-balance
sometime too sometimes that we see we
release I was you know a microsecond
late reacting to it so I don't want to
know those things so each day I
progressed which was a blessing and I
know some people at UCLA and one of the
things they told me right away with you
ever since you stepped on campus they
were like this guy darn a Holmes he's
not even draft eligible right now but he
lives in our film room he lives to work
is that something that you've always had
had in you since you were a five star or
is that something
that you had to learn along the way to
get better uh man is crazy I had that
since I was younger you know when I was
five I was waking up at five in the
morning to go train event ties that my
dad was open refrigerator where you
going I'm going to train the ho go get
you you don't need out it was a proud
moment for him and waking up get away
andand even it leaving the house has a
16 year old there he's got my license
and I'm driving you know 20 minutes
don't get a workout in before school or
so it just something I was instill
unique you know cuz I know time is of
the essence and once you start getting
relaxed you know that's when you give
the man next to you or a man behind you
that that leeway to take what you want
now we hear a lot of different things
whether it's from experts whether it's
from league scouts and how to label
players and and even today in the NFL
most base defenses are nickel defenses
but you get offended when people label
you as a slot corner he now is playing
everybody's perspective but it's like
you played on the outside a lot exactly
you know everybody has their different
thoughts of you know and that's a
blessing just people to recognize me but
definitely once I get to whoever's I get
to know they're not going to be able a
me as a nickel Claire you know I'm gonna
be a specialist you know I'm gonna be a
gun imma be a gem you know so it's not
gonna be no title or no boxing of Darnay
Holmes you know it is gonna be like this
guy Darnay Holmes he's contributed we
gotta find a way to get him on this
roster yeah and don't sell yourself
short I saw the 93 yard kick return as
well so we know what you could do with
the ball in your hands is there part of
you that that you you know you miss
offense or you just you love the
returning aspect is that something that
you take pride in in your game that you
know let's be real when the ball is in
your hands even on the interceptions
things happen yeah I'll tell you because
you know I want to be a game changer you
know I'm team oriented so if I had to
borrow my head I know that I could make
it
a game-changing play for us to progress
to what we want to do with that game
object if you know so the goal is to
blow now and I got to rock in my hand
I'm gonna take that to the crib you know
but sometimes you gotta be disciplining
him for up you know it may be a big suit
I got a sly
the game is over so you know what make
sure everything I do in life with the
team visions we've been looking at this
wide receiver class as well just like
the corner class it's loaded with talent
and a lot of that a lot of that talent
came from the conference that you played
in in the pac-12 and I know you played a
plenty of out of conference games as
well but who's the toughest receiver
that you covered during college during
college I'd definitely say CD Lam he was
my one the toughest opponents you know
he's he's smooth you know he's real
smooth at the top of the realm you know
he knows what he's doing before he has
to do it you know he know how to use
blind spots you know how to tackle there
is you know he's a polished up problem
sure you know after that game I stopped
polishing up I had to do you know so I
salute him for making be polished up art
is gonna polish up but he made me polish
it right away
you know he made me take note of the
things I had to fix not mainly got on
those things now I believe you committed
to a different staff when you were going
through this process as a five star and
then you go play under Chip Kelly is he
is crazy as everyone thinks he is cuz
he's got a crazy reputation from the NFL
back to college is there some wild
stories out there oh you know he has
different philosophies and cultures that
he encouraged people and a lot of people
are scared of letting go things that are
sabotaging them for region or for
potential you know once you're so
comfortable with the skin at your hand
you're afraid of stepping out that skin
for better you know because you already
know the results that you can get with
just the way walking in life now but he
made us walk in a different light you
know we made us müber with the
difference they can believe it
I took until I actually applied it I'm
doing good I'm flirting with you know
other people have problems with it
because they have some other things bigs
within but I knew I could place my trust
check eleena's constant just growing our
relationship what's the question that
you find teams are consistently asking
you whether it's something they want to
see you improve on or something that
they love about you what's that one
consistent thing that every time you do
one of these calls or one of these in
person sit downs what are they saying
what happened this year
really but you were hurt I mean I think
that's obvious there's AG Mia that's
amazing though they want to get the fool
and death into it they don't know when
the injury happened how the protocol
goes you're in you know why did you come
back in the time you came back was the
reason behind it you know and my main
thing for those listening you know it's
take ownership you know be yourself
afraid ownership you know don't lie you
know don't nobody own the bus and just
report what happened
that's all you can do it just reporting
it from there you know we should call a
house for sale so I have a funny story
for you a couple years ago I was in LA
and I'm a New York guy I was in LA to
help out with a bleacher report project
for LeBrons home Lakers debut and I
covered the draft that cover football
year-round so when we were done with
that I was like I'm gonna go up to
Pasadena and catch myself a game and I
always try to catch as many games as I
can in person throughout the year and
I'm watching this little Arizona running
back JJ Taylor break off a 60 65 yard
run and I'm like damn and there is a
corner that catches him at the 3 yard
line to punch the ball out and scoop it
in the end zone it is one of the
greatest plays I've ever seen in person
just walk me through that and I'm gonna
put the footage over this right now so
people watching are gonna see it
what was that like the appreciates
appreciates him for uh still recognizing
that play but the people to understand
that the reason I did that was because I
thought if he scored it's gonna be my
fault you know BK he hit that gap so
cold and I had you know you always got
to be cut the ball cut the boss I cut
the ball but he ran right past inside of
me I'm like oh no wait I'm not tonight
this happened you know I'm not gets
critiqued on film with a Tim discorso
you know right away on my arm either
chasing down and once I got calls all
night
I see no right let me see what this
about there you know when I scooped it I
was about to take off
I'm not to take off but my teammate who
got picked I finally several minutes
before he and he had a pic of his own he
took it out he to get 20-plus y'all
so you coming out the end zone you got
to make sure that we did great field
position so he was very right there when
I scooped the ball up me pushing you
like get down I'm right it was great
because I remember you picking it up and
you look up and you look left look right
and I'm like yeah we know what he can do
with the ball in his hands he's gonna
one more question before I let you go
because I know you got a crazy schedule
right now and I left a plans right now
because it's yeah job day plans is just
you know yet my less than ten gathering
you know make sure you suck this is left
to tell you gather it uh make sure that
everyone's six feet away but not outside
of that because you know give my
immediate family around you know I know
my supporters I mean you know my
girlfriend is taking care of everything
that relates to draft day I'm gonna make
sure that my family you know gets the
recognition I think they need to get you
know and from my side you know I'm just
preparing myself mentally you know I
want to be at peace when job day comes
you know I want to know that in the day
is a blessing to know that my name is
gonna be caught but I don't know when my
name is going to be cause so what I'm
just praying about is allowing the mana
bug provide me with the patience and
assurance that the dice Carl and I are
supposed to me you know no matter what
round no matter what organization I go
to it is a huge opportunity though my
main the whole process like I just want
to go to organization where a coach can
add tremendous value to the organization
can add tremendous value Nate sharp me
up as a man shot my sporty awesome
player so right now when I'm going to
snow keeping my mind clear and it's
being at a state of living my faith and
belief well I think you're gonna be very
successful wherever you end up darn a
home's rootin for you man can't wait to
see where that is and we're wishing you
nothing but the best here from Bleacher
Report going forward man yes I
appreciate you guys
Darnay thanks so much man I really
appreciate the time always no doubt all
right good luck with everything man I
see it later